sein buch eine kurze geschichte der
menschheit wurde zum megaseller mark
zuckerberg im fall ist so lektüre barack
obama und bill gates ebenso geschrieben
hat dass der preisgekrönte historiker
juval harari er lehrt an der hebräischen
universität in jerusalem unter ist heute
zu gast bei uns im studio in berlin
das buch eine kurze geschichte der
menschheit endete mit einem cliffhanger
der homo sapiens hat 70.000 jahre die
erde dominiert doch die
erfolgsgeschichte könnte eines tages zu
ende gehen
in seinem neuen buch ko-modus sagt die
wahl harari wir stehen tatsächlich kurz
vor dem ende der menschheit wie wir sie
konnte das müssen wir diskutieren
herzlich willkommen ja wie sieht denn
aus sind wir menschen kurz vor dem
aussterben
aber es ist kein ende wie in einem
hollywood film in dem roboter verrückt
werden und alle menschen töten
es ist wahrscheinlicher dass wir neue
technologien nutzen werden vor allem
biotechnologie und künstliche
intelligenz um uns zu verändern und in
weesen upzugraden die sich viel mehr von
uns unterscheiden als wir uns von den
neandertalern oder schimpansen
ich denke also nicht dass in 200 jahren
menschen wie wir die erde bevölkern
werden unsere nachfahren werden eine
form von cyber wesen sein die das
zukünftige leben dominieren
warum haben wir etwas zu tun sie
schreiben in ihrem buch ja sehr
ausführlich darüber dass es uns
eigentlich wunderbar geht zurzeit wir
sind nicht mehr bedroht von den üblichen
gefahren die wir einmal hart sind in
unserem leben es gibt keine oder nicht
mehr viele ansteckende krankheiten die
uns dahinraffen die pest oder kochen
es gibt nicht mehr so viele welthunger
sondern wir sterben eher weil wir zu
viel essen eine zu dick werden um es
gibt auch nicht mehr so viele kriege
auch wenn ihr das fast nicht glauben
können wenn nach syrien blicken
warum also sollen wir jetzt plötzlich
finden
wir wollen was anderes werden auf
menschen wenn ich doch so gut haben weil
wir mehr macht und glück haben wollen
und wir glauben wir könnten das
erreichen indem wir unseren körper
unser gehirn und sogar unseren geist
verändern
im verlauf der geschichte über tausende
von jahren haben die menschen versucht
macht über die welt zu gewinnen um sie
zu verändern ihren wünschen anzupassen
und so ihre bedürfnisse zu befriedigen
doch es hat nicht funktioniert wir haben
mehr macht denn je erlangt sind aber
nicht wirklich glücklicher geworden
wir menschen sind heute 1000 mal
mächtiger als in der steinzeit aber es
gibt keine anzeichen dafür dass wir
zufriedener sind als die menschen von
damals deshalb verlegen wir nun den
fokus nach innen und sagen uns
anscheinend genügte es nicht die welt um
uns herum zu verändern
wir müssen unsere innere welt verändern
unseren körper unser gehirn ich stelle
mir vor dass die wichtigsten produkte
des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts nicht
autos waffen oder nahrungsmittel sein
werden sondern körper und gehirne wir
beginnen zu lernen wie wir diese mit
biotechnologie maschinellem lernen und
künstlicher intelligenz herstellen
können und dem streben nach mehr macht
und glück werden wir uns verändern und
zu etwas anderem upgraden
ein anderer typus von mensch zu werden
sie sprechen von einem homo dem
währenddessen die vorher homo sapiens
waren also wir beide sind ja glaube ich
immer noch groß ab um diese geschichte
zu verstehen und sie sind ja historiker
sie zeichnen alles in einer großen
entwicklung nach müssen wir vielleicht
zuerst einen schritt noch zurückstehen
und sie sagen dass alles diese die
sehnsucht danach das glück wie nun
selber zu suchen hat mit dem begonnen
was sie humanismus nennen
was ist denn passiert in diesen
humanismus
was passierte im humanismus der
humanismus ist ein ziemlich spätes
phänomen er ist nicht älter als 200 oder
300 jahre während dem größten teil die
geschichte glaubten die menschen die
autorität kommen von außen vor allem von
oben von den göttern über den wolken in
der politik der ökonomie und die ethik
sagten uns die götter was gut und was
schlecht ist und wie wir uns verhalten
müssen
in den letzten zwei drei jahrhunderten
erlebten wir dann die humanistische
revolution die besagt die autorität
kommt nicht von außen sondern von innen
hauptquelle die autorität sind die
menschen mit ihren gefühlen und ihren
freien entscheidungen in der politik
hatten könige oder kaiser zuvor ihre
autorität von den göttern von gottes
gnaden
dann kann man die humanisten und sagten
nein quelle die autorität sollten die
gefühle der menschen sein
wenn es also darum geht wird der nächste
präsident der usa wird oder ob
großbritannien in der eu bleiben soll
oder nicht fragen wir weder gott noch
die königin oder den bischof von
canterbury
wir bitten jeden einzelnen britischen
bürger um seine meinung autorität
entspringt also den gefühlen und
entscheidungen die individuen
das gleiche gilt für die wirtschaft hier
zählt der slogan der kunde hat immer
recht er ist die höchste autorität in
der wirtschaft das gilt auch für die
ethik früher haben autoritäten
festgelegt was gut oder schlecht war
es stand in der bibel oder wurde vom
papst verkündet hinsichtlich der
homosexualität hieß es zum beispiel
es ist schlecht wenn zwei männer sex
haben oder heiraten warum weil es so in
der bibel steht
dann kamen die humanisten und sagten es
spielt keine rolle was in der bibel
steht einzig die gefühle der menschen
zählen
wenn zwei männer sich lieben und
niemandem schaden was kann daran falsch
sein
die höchste autorität sind die
menschlichen gefühle ich verstehe sehr
gut was sie erzählen und gleichzeitig
denke ich stimmt das bild wirklich dass
die moderne sozusagen der abschied von
gott bedeutet oder ist wirklich unsere
zeit eine zeit in der der humanismus
sich so sehr durchgesetzt hat dass wir
nicht mehr zu beten brauchen um
glücklich zu sein ist es nicht gerade so
dass die meisten leute heute verzweifelt
das sind als früher sie sagen selber es
gibt nicht mehr so viele kriegsopfer
sondern sehr viel mehr menschen nehmen
sich das leben sie bringen sich um es
gibt mehr opfer von suiziden die
kriegsopfer hat die menschen seien ja
nicht glücklich scheinlich glücklich zu
sein
tatsächlich sind die menschen nicht
glücklicher als zuvor
obwohl ihre lebensbedingungen viel
besser geworden sind
dafür gibt es zwei hauptgründe zuerst
einmal hängt das glück die menschen von
ihren erwartungen ab und nicht von den
objektiven lebensbedingungen wenn sie
bekommen was sie sich wünschen sind sie
glücklich wenn sie etwas wollen egal was
und es nicht bekommen sind sie
unzufrieden und das problem ist je
besser die lebensbedingungen werden
desto größer sind die erwartungen
heute genießen wir zahlreiche dinge von
denen die menschen früher nur träumen
konnten
aber wir sind nicht zufrieden denn wir
wollen vielmehr auch auf einer tieferen
ebene reagiert das menschliche gehirn
auf erfolg und genuss grundsätzlich
nicht mit zufriedenheit sondern mit dem
wunsch noch mehr zu haben
egal was wir erreichen wir wollen mehr
ja sicher wenn die menschen zufrieden
wären mit dem was sie haben würde der
kapitalismus zusammenbrechen darauf
gründete er aber dieses phänomen ist
viel älter als der kapitalismus das ist
keine moderne erscheint
schon im mittelalter
wer damals könig wurde und sein reich
hatte war selten zufrieden damit
er wollte mehr erobern aber auch die
einnahme des nachbar reiches befriedigte
ihn nicht er wollte noch eines und noch
eines und so schuf er sein imperium
diese neigung des geistes auf erfolg mit
dem verlangen nach mehr zu reagieren
statt mit befriedigung ist kein modernes
phänomen sondern teil der menschlichen
natur
der kapitalismus baut darauf auf ist
aber nicht die ursache bei diesem punkt
bleiben dass gott sozusagen abgeschafft
werden kann
am ende des humanismus am punkt an dem
wir jetzt stehen
dann kann man sagen die die empirie
weist aber in eine andere richtung ich
habe eine eine grafik mitgenommen vom
pew research center die mich selber auch
erstaunt hat wie sie in die zahlen von
2010 16 4 prozent sind konfessionsfreie
menschen 2050 hochgerechnet rechnen sie
nur noch mit 13 2 das heißt sogar
weniger menschen werden sozusagen
gottlos seien im jahr 2050 die muslime
nehmen zu das heißt das widerspricht
doch eigentlich dieser these die sie
vertreten dass gott sozusagen auf der
müllhalde der ideen die menschen glauben
immer noch an gott er ist einfach viel
weniger wichtig ich sage nicht gott sei
verschwunden
ich komme aus israel und weiß sehr wohl
dass die meisten menschen vor allem im
nahen osten immer noch an gott glauben
aber er ist weniger wichtig als je zuvor
in der geschichte
die menschen glauben an ihn weil ihre
gefühle ihnen sagen dass sie das tun
sollten
sogar in der religion sind gefühle die
hauptquelle die autorität beispiel dafür
ist die große gay pride parade dieser
zehn jahren in jerusalem statt findet
das ist eine der seltenen harmonischen
tage in der stadt die sonst von
konflikten und hass dominiert wird
einmal im jahr
anlässlich der gay parade herrscht
harmonie weil alle gläubigen muslime
juden und christen sich zusammentun um
gegen die gay parade zu protestieren
sie haben ein gemeinsames anliegen aber
sie argumentieren nicht ihr dürft keine
gay parade veranstalten weil gott sagt
das sei eine sünde
sie bringen die gefühle ins spiel und
sagen wir wollen keine gay parade in der
heiligen stadt jerusalem weil das unsere
gefühle verletzt sogar sie haben gelernt
von menschlichen gefühlen anstatt von
göttlichen geboten zu sprechen
es gibt noch einen wichtigeren punkt
wenn sie die letzten 100 jahre zurück
schauen und sich fragen welches waren
die wichtigsten erfindungen entdeckungen
oder neuen ideen im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert ist das sehr schwer zu
beantworten weil es so viele mögliche
kandidaten gibt
das internet computer atomwaffen
antibiotika es gibt so vieles ja aber
dann fragen sie sich was war die
wichtigste entdeckung erfindung oder
neue idee der traditionellen religionen
und da gibt es nichts was haben rabbiner
priester und mullahs erfunden dass man
im gleichen atemzug nennen könnte mit
den antibiotika den feminismus oder dem
computer
die traditionellen religionen gibt es
immer noch aber sie haben sich von einer
kreativen kraft in eine reaktive kraft
verwandelt im mittelalter waren die
religionen serie
die christliche kirche war im damaligen
europa die instanz die dem heutigen
silicon valley am nächsten kommt dass
sie gründete viele universitäten und
leistete pionierarbeit in der
datenverarbeitung
sie erfand alle möglichen systeme um
daten zu sammeln sie zu analysieren und
archive zu erstellen
darin war die kirche führend jede könig
der eine bürokratische struktur eine
administration schaffen wollte wandte
sich an die priester und mönche aber
heute sind die kirche und die meisten
religiösen institutionen nicht mehr als
eine reaktive kraft sie erbringen in
keinem bereich pionierleistungen als das
internet erfunden wurde fragten sich die
rabbiner was tun wir nun damit sollen
wir den gläubigen juden erlauben es zu
benutzen oder nicht oder die neuen
impulse des feminismus die priester
fragen sich was soll das wie reagieren
wir auf diese aufrührerischen ideen der
eben diesen großen bogen zeichnet und
für mich ist es auch so wenn ich dieses
buch lese dass ich die ganze zeit denke
ich möchte über alle diese thesen mit
ihnen gleich sprechen und ich finde das
alles hochinteressant ich habe mich nur
gefragt ist es nicht trotzdem eine these
die stark auf die westlich gedachte welt
zutrifft die eben diese sehnsucht habt
den menschen weiter zu entwickeln weil
sie nämlich nicht mehr auf gott gesetzt
hat und gott jetzt sozusagen in der
eigenen überhöhung sucht das ist so
ungefähr
eine der kernthesen währenddessen ich
den eindruck habe eben schauen sie in
den nahen osten gibt es da nicht die
andere bewegen dass man sagt nein wir
wollen eben genau die politik wieder mit
der religion zusammen bringen wir wollen
eben genau dass die religion wieder die
macht haben aber es ist wie im
neunzehnten jahrhundert mit der
industriellen revolution
es war nicht so dass plötzlich die ganze
welt an die macht die industrie glaubte
an die dampfkraft die elektrizität die
telegrafische übertragung von
informationen
es waren einige wenige länder welche der
der welt anführten zuerst großbritannien
dann frankreich deutschland die meisten
länder wurden von der industrialisierung
nicht erfasst und blieben weit zurück
und die wenigen länder welche die
industrialisierung vorantrieben begannen
die ganze welt zu kontrollieren und
machten sie zu dem planeten den wir
heute kennen sie prägt nicht nur
großbritannien sondern auch afrika asien
dem nahen osten und südamerika länder
oder kulturen die auch im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert zurück
bleiben und sich nicht an der neuen
revolution die biotechnologie und
künstliche intelligenz beteiligen werden
erneut opfer der neuen großmächte nicht
mehr unbedingt die europäischen länder
sondern vielleicht china und südkorea
aber die wenigen länder welche die neue
revolution der biotechnologie und
künstliche intelligenz anführen werden
noch mehr macht erlangen als
großbritannien und frankreich im
neunzehnten jahrhundert sie werden die
gesamte welt des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert prägen
sie werden nicht unbedingt dazu gedrängt
mit zu ziehen sondern vielleicht besetzt
und ausgebeutet wie indien china und
fast ganz afrika im neunzehnten
jahrhundert
ich denke die wichtigste frage für
praktisch alle länder der welt lautet
führen wir diese revolution an oder
bleiben wir zurück und wer heute
zurückbleibt ist in größerer gefahr als
afrika und china im neunzehnten
jahrhundert als diese sich nicht
rechtzeitig an der industriellen
revolution beteiligten und deshalb von
den wenigen industriellen großmächten
von großbritannien frankreich und später
japan und den usa erobert und
ausgebeutet wurden
homo sapiens mehr sein sondern ho
modells werden dann haben sie am anfang
schon gesagt es gibt verschiedene
möglichkeiten wie dieses upgrade
vorangetrieben werden kann sie bieten
eigentlich drei möglichkeiten an sie
sagen das könnte genetische selektion
sein oder genetische verbesserungen
dann wären wir vielleicht 200 jahren so
etwas wie designer babys die erwachsen
geworden sind das könnte so was sein die
cyborgs das heißt wir beginnen uns
technisch zu verbessern und werden halb
zu maschinen oder es könnte etwas sein
die raubfische intelligence also
künstliche intelligenzen androide
roboter die eigentlich menschen ähnliche
qualitäten haben aber intelligenz mäßig
uns noch weit überlegen sind
drei typen wie man who modems werden
kann welchen typen würden sie wählen
wenn sie lernen könnten
ich persönlich halte es nicht unbedingt
für das wichtigste ziel im leben ein
super mensch zu werden und diese immense
macht zu besitzen
das strebe ich nicht an
und ich empfehle auch niemandem es zu
tun ich sage einzig als historiker das
geschieht momentan sie können es überall
beobachten wir sprechen davon dass
menschen mit computern verschmelzen und
cyborgs werden zu wesen die halb mensch
und halb computer oder roboter sind
das ist keine zukunftsvision diese
prozess ist bereits im gang menschen
verschmelzen schon heute mit ihren
smartphones mit ihren facebook account
und computer immer mehr arbeiten für die
wir früher auf unser gehirn oder unseren
körper angewiesen waren lagern wir an
dieser geräte aus und schon bald werden
wir sie direkt mit unserem körper
verbinden
dann ist es nicht mehr so dass ich ein
smartphone habe das smartphone ist ein
teil von mir
die nächste evolutionsstufe in diesem
bereich wird man mit biometrischen
sensoren erzielen
diese werden teil unseres körpers sein
und aus unserem inneren ständig
biometrische daten an ein smartphone
oder einen computer übermitteln und im
gegenzug befehle erhalten
ich kann ihnen an einigen beispielen
zeigen wie sich dadurch der alltag der
individuen verändert sie alle diese
partner vermittlungsagenturen im
internet stellen sie sich vor dass sie
einen biometrischen sensor auf sich
tragen sie gehen eine straße lang und
sehen jemanden der ihnen gefällt
die app auf ihrem smartphone registriert
sofort dass sie diese person sexuell
anziehend finden denn ihr blutdruck
steigt an und ihre pupillen weiten sich
und soweit möglich merken sie es selber
gar nicht aber die app weißes und sie
kann das smartphone die anderen personen
kontaktieren und herausfinden ob diese
sie auch attraktiv findet dieser prozess
muss nicht von ihrem gehirn ihren augen
oder ihrem willen gesteuert werden diese
übernimmt das smartphone für sie und
bestimmt zunehmend ihr sexual oder
liebesleben noch machen sondern sie
beschreiben erst einmal und sagen als
historiker interessiert sich die
bewegung sie interessiert die evolution
des menschen und sie sagen da passiert
etwas ganz ganz grundlegendes im moment
das bin ich schon an sich interessant
basars historiker in die zukunft schauen
was macht eigentlich ein historiker
wende in die zukunft blickt und ich
versuche nicht die zukunft vorherzusagen
denn das ist unmöglich
niemand weiß was in 20
oder 50 jahren passieren wird ich
versuche viel mehr verschiedene
möglichkeiten aufzuzeigen
ich bin weniger an der technologie an
und für sich interessiert sondern an
deren sozialen politischen und
philosophischen tragweite
ich bin nicht auf computerwissenschaften
oder biologie spezialisiert daher habe
ich kein interesse an den technischen
aspekten des maschinellen lernens oder
der gentechnologie und mir fehlt das
nötige wissen aber aufgrund meiner
kenntnisse über frühere revolutionen in
der geschichte versuche ich aufzuzeigen
wie sich die künstliche intelligenz auf
den stellenmarkt auf familienstrukturen
liebesbeziehungen und religionen
auswirken wird
diese überlegungen bringe ich als
historiker in die zukunftsforschung ein
beschreiben was mit uns menschen
passieren wird eben an dieser
schnittstelle zum homo der jungs hin
dann haben sie jetzt gerade zum beispiel
beschrieben wie sehr wir verschmelzen
könnten mit den maschinen und ein stück
weit sagen sie da aber auch im buch ist
hier zu weit kommen dass der mensch sich
als mensch abschafft und das hat auch
damit zu tun dass sie sagen der mensch
ist überhaupt nicht so speziell wie
immer gemeint haben
der mensch ist eigentlich wenn wir genau
hinschauen nur ein algorithmus das
müssen sie erklären
das ist schwierig grundsätzlich geht es
um folgende idee menschen besitzen
keinen freien willen der freie wille ist
eine art mythos den wir vom christentum
von früheren traditionen und religionen
übernommen habe menschliche gefühle
basieren vielmehr auf sehr schnellen
kalkulationen des nervensystems und des
gehirns
davon gehen die lebenswissenschaften
momentan aus eindrücke und gefühle sind
das resultat von extrem schnellen
kalkulationen oder algorithmen die
wiederum von der natürlichen selektion
geprägt sind
ich gebe ihnen wieder ein
das klingt sehr abstrakt was heißt es
dass emotionen und sinnesempfindungen
algorithmen oder kalkulationen sind
nehmen wir nicht menschen sondern tiere
zum beispiel paviane
auch sie haben emotionen und
sinneseindrücke angenommen sie sind ein
pavian in der afrikanischen savanne und
sie sehen einen baum mit banane nicht
weit von diesem baum entfernt entdeckten
sie auch einen löwen und sie müssen eine
entscheidung treffen riskiere ich mein
leben für die bananen oder nicht solche
entscheidungen mussten tiere in den
milliarden jahren der evolution fällen
um überleben zu können
dies ist im grunde eine
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung wie groß ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass der löwe
mich frist wenn ich versuche die banalen
zu pflücken
dagegen steht die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass ich verhungere wenn ich die bananen
nicht fressen
um zu überleben muss der pavian diese
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung machen dafür
braucht ihr viele informationen
informationen über die bananen wie weit
weg sind sie wie viele sind es sind sie
groß oder klein greif oder grün
drei kleine grüne bananen sind etwas
ganz anderes als zehn große süße bananen
der pavian braucht außerdem
informationen über den löwen wie weit
ist er entfernt wie schnell kann er
ihnen schläft er oder ist er wach zudem
benötigt der pavian informationen über
sich selber wie schnell kann ich rennen
wie hungrig bin ich und so weiter alle
diese daten muss der pavian in einem
bruchteil einer sekunde gegeneinander
abwägen wie macht er das nicht mit stift
und papier oder einem taschenrechner der
ganze körper und vor allem das was wir
wahrnehmungen und emotionen nennen sind
seine
maschine die daten werden aufgenommen
durch sinneseindrücke durch das was der
pavian riecht berührt oder sieht und in
sekundenbruchteilen kalkuliert sein
gehirn diese wahrscheinlichkeiten
das ergebnis zeigt sich als gefühl
entweder ist es mut wurde es ist angst
dass wir emotionen nennen sind
algorithmen berechnete
wahrscheinlichkeiten und zwar nicht nur
bei pavianen und löwen sondern auch bei
menschen interessant oder gar tut auch
weh weil den jungs so vorstellen dann
gehen sie weiter und sagen okay
und jetzt gibt es algorithmen da draußen
irgendwelche computerprogramme sensoren
biometrische sensoren haben sie schon
genannt oder mit derzeit kleinste nano
computer die durch unsere blutbahn und
flitzen und messungen vornehmen und dann
werden die algorithmus sagen wie wir
entscheiden sollen weil die nämlich
zusammen mit unserem ganzen
evolutionären programm kurzgeschlossen
sehr viel treffsicherer wissen was wir
sagen nicht gut ist ja die idee ist
folgende bis jetzt waren unsere
biochemischen algorithmen unsere gefühle
die besten im universum
sie wurden von millionen jahren die
revolution geprägt und die menschen
taten gut daran ihnen zu vertrauen
jetzt sind wir nahe daran elektronischer
algorithmen zu kreieren die uns besser
kennen als wir selber und daher besser
sagen können wie wir uns verhalten und
welche entscheidungen wir fällen sollen
es beginnt mit sehr einfachen dingen zum
beispiel mit der frage welches buch man
lesen soll früher im humanistischen
zeitalter wählten sie ihre lektüre
aufgrund von gefühlen und von
empfehlungen einiger freunde oder
familienmitglieder
doch heute locken sie sich im internet
im amazon buchversand 1
und sofort erscheint ein algorithmus und
gibt ihnen zu verstehen ich kenne sie
ich bin ringen gefolgt und haben daten
über sie gesammelt und aufgrund dieser
daten und statistiken von millionen
andere leser empfehle ich ihnen dieses
oder jenes buch doch das ist noch sehr
einfach es gibt eine nächste komplexere
stufe die wir bereits erleben denn es
werden immer mehr daten über sie
gesammelt
während sie zb ein buch auf kindle lesen
ließ das buch sie zum ersten mal in der
geschichte lesen bücher menschen
deswegen meine bücher bei amazon
bestellen weil ich nämlich darf lesen
will was ich lesen will
und sie sagen jetzt liebe frau gleich
vergessen wird es gibt kein ich aber wie
wissen sie welche bücher wirklich gut
sind für sie für welche sparte sie sich
auch interessieren ob sie unterhaltung
intellektuelle bereicherung oder sonst
etwas wünschen wie wissen sie was gut
ist für sie momentan sind sie auf ihren
instinkt angewiesen
meine entscheidungen zu meinen
entscheidungen gehört auch dass ich mich
täusche dass ich auf die nase fallen
dass ich scheitere aber das bin ich
what if you're gone
aber was wenn sie bessere bücher
entdecken könnten die ihr leben mehr
bereichern bücher von denen sie nach der
lektüre sagen das ist ein gutes recht
ich danke amazon für diese empfehlung
ich wäre nie von mir aus darauf gestoßen
dank amazon riesig es nun ich denke
immer mehr
das geschieht auch um uns herum bereits
durchgesetzt hat sich wie die leute sich
orientieren um von a nach b zu gelangen
wer früher von hier zum hauptbahnhof
fahren wollte vertraute seinem instinkt
und seinen gefühlen
heute vertrauen mehr und mehr leute auf
google maps sie kommen an eine kreuzung
und rollen instinktiv rechts
wegen doch google warnt sie dort geraten
sie in einen stau biegen sie links ab
immer mehr leute vertrauen aufgrund
ihrer erfahrung google maps mehr als
ihren eigenen gefühlen weil der
algorithmus besser ist ich gehe davon
aus dass diese tendenz zunimmt nicht nur
bei der wahl von büchern sondern bei
viel wichtigeren dingen wie der wahl von
freunden oder liebes partnern in nicht
allzu ferner zukunft wenn genügend daten
und computer leistung zur verfügung
stehen werden die menschen google maps
amazon oder facebook vertrauen um sogar
ihre freunde oder ehepartner auszuwählen
sie haben ein problem bis jetzt
umschifft oder wir haben es gemeinsam
umschifft nämlich das was die
philosophen das hart problem nennen das
problem des bewusstseins weil wenn wir
den menschen einfach aus egoismus
beschreiben der eben verbessert werden
kann mit zusätzlichen externen
algorithmen dann stellt sich die frage
wo genau ist eigentlich das was sie
früher seele 19 heute bewusstsein nennen
wo etwas platz und gibt es da nicht doch
einen unterschied zwischen uns auf
menschen und tieren vielleicht gewissen
tieren und vor allem eben eben welcher
künstlicher intelligenz
nun wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen
seele und bewusstsein
die seele ist ein mythologisches konzept
wir haben keinerlei beweis für die
existenz der see sofern sie unter seele
eine individuelle ewige essenz verstehen
die sich nicht verändert von der geburt
bis zum tod und die womöglich sogar
darüber hinaus für immer bestehen bleibt
wir haben keinerlei beweise dass so
etwas tatsächlich existiert es ist nur
ein mythos consciousness und wie er das
bewusstsein hingegen ist ein strom
subjektive erfahrungen die wir moment
für moment erleben
es ist das real sste was es gibt die
ganze welt könnte auch nur eine art
traum sein
eine matrix wie im gleichnamigen film
aber mein bewusstsein ist real
es ist das einzige auf der welt für das
es keine zweifel gibt wenn ich schmerzen
habe kenne ich vielleicht die ursache
dafür nicht aber die empfindung der
schmerzen ist real
momentan haben wir keine gute theorie
dafür was bewusstsein ist oder wie es
entsteht
wissenschaftler vermuten dass das gehirn
irgendwie bewusste erfahrungen
produziert aber wir haben keine idee wie
das vor sich geht wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe die position von daniel dennett
den großen philosophen ein stück weit
auch eine sehr physikalische position
dass man sagt auch bewusstsein ist
zurückführbar auf algorithmen auf
physikalische prozesse biochemische
prozesse des grüns ablaufen aber sie ist
eben nichts mystisches an diesem
bewusstsein die lebenswissenschaften
gehen allgemein von der theorie aus dass
irgendwelche bio chemische und
elektrische prozesse im gehirn und
bewusste erfahrungen schaffen wenn
milliarden neuronen im gehirn in einem
gewissen muster feuern empfinden sie
liebe feuerten die neuronen in einem
anderen muster empfinden sie hasst das
ist die allgemeine theorie aber bis
heute haben wir keine ahnung wie und
warum das passiert warum hat man wenn
milliarden neuronen feuern die
subjektive empfindung von liebe das
wissen wir ganz einfach nicht aber das
beste an die wissenschaft ist dass man
anders als in der religion keine
fantasievolle theorie erfinden muss wenn
man etwas nicht weiß man kann einfach
sagen wir wissen es nicht hart problem
weil dies nicht nächsten beherrscht ich
wirklich gelöst haben und sagen sie
lange haben die an gott geglaubt unsere
religion bestand darin zb an eine seele
zu glauben auch daran zu glauben dass
der
die krone der schöpfung sei was ganz
spezielles was kein roboter je sein wird
was kein tier je war
und jetzt kommt eine neue religion mit
dem homo der modems der glaubt an den
data ich muss was genau ist das für eine
religion der data is muss beruht auf
folgende idee wenn ein externer
algorithmus genügend daten von mir
besitzt und genug rechenleistung
erbringt versteht er mich besser als ich
mich selber verstehe und hat darum die
autorität entscheidungen bezüglich
meines lebens zu fällen
in der religion geht es letztendlich um
autorität
es geht nicht um gott den himmel oder
die sünde über jahrtausende erzählte die
wichtigste religiöse geschichte die
autorität stamme von gott davon handeln
mehrere mythologien in den letzten zwei
bis drei jahrhunderten revidierte die
humanistische revolution diese
geschichte und verkündete nein die
autorität entspringt menschlichen
gefühlen und jetzt erleben wir die
nächste revolution mit dem dadaismus der
besagt autorität kommt weder von dort
noch von menschlichen gefühlen sondern
von daten darüber gesprochen dass dazu
auch noch gehört nämlich der umgang mit
dem tod sie sagen der tod wird in
zukunft mit dieser partei ist ischen
revolution mit der revolution zum homo
dem skin ein technisches problem werden
und was ich ja auch etwas was viele
touristen sagen ray kurzweil ist ein
berühmtes beispiel dafür
zusammen mit einem google suchen
unternehmen sind die daran den tod
abzuschaffen sie sagen bereits 2050
werden die regelmäßig hingehen einen
biologischen reset button drücken können
uns generalüberholen lassen und dann
können wir locker 400 jahre auf ihren
glauben sie das wirklich
ich denke dass es noch verfrüht
im jahr 2050 werden wir noch nicht die
nötige technologie haben um das leben
unendlich fortsetzen zu können
doch in ein oder zwei 100 jahren könnte
es durchaus möglich sein
aber schon heute eigentlich bereits seit
100 oder 200 jahren haben wir ein neues
konzept des todes er ist zum technischen
problem geworden
dies nachdem er fast in der gesamten
menschheitsgeschichte ein metaphysisches
phänomen darstellte und für die meisten
religionen heilig war
sie sahen den tod als essentiellen teil
des lebens er verliert im leben erst
bedeutung
denken sie ans alte ägypten mit seinen
pyramiden und mumien denken sie ans
christentum und den islam
sie alle haben ohne tod keine bedeutung
ohne leben nach dem tod ohne himmel und
hölle gibt es kein christentum
der tod ist also grundlegend aber in den
letzten zwei drei jahrhunderten kamen
neue weltlicher ideologien auf welche
die bedeutung des lebens nicht mehr
länger von tod abhängig machen
für sie ist der tod nur ein
unerfreuliches technisches problem
nehmen sie den kommunismus den
sozialismus den feminismus den
liberalismus diese ideologien machen die
bedeutung des lebens nicht mehr vom tod
abhängig was passiert mit einem
kommunisten wenn er stirbt wer weiß
marx beschäftigte die frage was nach dem
tod geschieht ganz einfach nicht auch im
feminismus fragt man oder frau sich
nicht was nach dem sterben passiert der
tod wurde aus der gleichung entfernt
menschen sterben nicht weil es zum
göttlichen plan gehört sondern weil sie
einen herzinfarkt erleiden und der
herzinfarkt ist auf ein anderes
technisches problem zurückzuführen
die stiftung des todes die kann ja auf
zwei arten geschehen philosophisch
gesehen man kann sagen einerseits es
gibt diese idee dass wir weiterleben
nach dem tod und der sinn besteht darin
der sinn des todes besteht darin dass es
noch weitergeht gibt aber auch den
initialen der sinn hat der tod hat einen
sinn für unser jetziges da sein weil nur
dadurch dass wir endlich sind wird es
nicht langweilig werden ansonsten wir
gefangen in der ewigen wiederholung und
genau diesen punkt widerspricht
ray kurzweil und ich möchte dass mit
ihnen ganz kurz anschauen was er dazu
sagt
wenn wir die quali lebensverlängerung
ohne radikale lebens erweiterung hätten
würde es langweilig werden
aber es wird beides geschehen wir werden
unsere persönlichkeit erweitern wir
werden computer in unserem körper haben
und so unser wissen und unsere
fähigkeiten
wir werden millionen virtueller
umgebungen direkt erfahren können wir
werden unsere emotionalen fähigkeiten
vergrößern
wir werden kreative werden alles dinge
die das leben lebenswert machen ich
denke es kommen auch viele probleme auf
uns zu wenn wir das leben beliebig
verlängern können
zuerst einmal wird es wahrscheinlich
sehr teuer sein
zumindest für die ersten generationen
also haben nur die reichen die chance
jahrhundertelang schön und jung zu
bleiben
das wird gewaltige wut auslösen in der
armen bevölkerung
denn während der bisherigen
menschheitsgeschichte war der tod die
große ausgleichende macht die armen
konnten sagen die reichen haben zwar ein
gutes leben aber sie müssen wie wir
sterben
doch stellen sie sich eine welt vor in
dir nur die armen sterben und die
reichen weiterleben das wird viele
wütend machen
und wer reich ist hat viel mehr angst
als zuvor denn wir reden hier nicht von
unsterblichkeit
sie können immer noch sterben sie haben
die möglichkeit unendlich zu leben dank
neuer behandlungen aber wenn sie zb von
einem auto überfahren werden sind sie
tot das kann niemand rückgängig machen
die angst vor dem tod wird also größer
sein denn je
die menschen werden keine risiken
eingehen wollen
es war heute riskant hierher zu reisen
das flugzeug hätte abstürzen können doch
da ich so oder so sterben werde bin ich
bereit gewisse risiken einzugehen
aber da viele die chance ewig zu leben
nicht verpassen wollen weil sie diesen
oder jenen fehler machen gibt es wohl
nicht nur mehr wird sondern auch viel
mehr angst als je zuvor
das andere ist dass mir ehrlich gesagt
dieser grenzenlose optimismus irgendwie
übertrieben scheint obwohl ich auch
immer wieder denke sie bringen so viele
beispiel im buch das man sich schon
hinterfragen muss in den überzeugungen
die man habt ich habe zb die starke
überzeugung dass künstliche wesen
roboter nie wirklich kreativ werden
können oder nicht so kreativ wie wir
ich habe ein musikstück mitgebracht
kennen sie diese musik
[Musik]
ich kenne dieses bestimmte stück nicht
aber im buch beschreibe ich ein
computerprogramm das musik im stil von
johann sebastian bach komponiert und die
meisten menschen können wie auch ich den
unterschied zwischen seine musik und der
computer komposition nicht erkennen das
computerprogramm kamen zu schreiben sie
es 5000 choräle in einem tag komponieren
und wenn es um kunst geht stellt sich
einmal mehr eine philosophische frage
was ist die wichtigste aufgabe der kunst
gewisse leute finden kunst solle vor
allem gefühle auslösen
doch wenn kunst emotionen wecken soll
werden computer sehr bald viel bessere
künstler sein als menschen
denn aufgrund ihrer datenmenge und
rechenleistung können sie viel besser
mit unseren emotionen spielen als jeder
menschliche künstler
sie verfügen nicht über eigene emotionen
computer haben kein bewusstsein sie
haben keine gefühle
aber sie haben die fähigkeit die
emotionen der menschen viel präziser zu
manipulieren oder zu inspirieren als
jeder menschliche künstler konzert gehe
dann möchte ich aber nicht nur den
perfekten klang sondern ich schätze es
die musiker zu sehen von denen ich weiß
sie sind wie ich aus fleisch und blut
und die haben diese dieses perfekte
können
die sind in der lage so zu spielen wie
ich es nie beherrschen werde und baust
zu erleben berührt mich ja auch nicht
alleine der perfekte klang und eine
maschine würde ich nie gleich an affen
bewundern oder glauben sie da wird sich
auch ändern
ich denke das wird sich ändern
es hängt damit zusammen was sie erwarten
sie sind mit gewissen erwartungen an die
kunst aufgewachsen und sind vielleicht
entsetzt über etwas das diese
erwartungen enttäuscht aber angenommen
musik hinter einer leinwand sie werden
davon berührt und inspiriert und spüren
liebe angst wut was auch immer dann
nimmt man die leinwand weg und sie sehen
dass dort keine menschen sind sondern
nur ein computer was würden sie dann
denken ihre emotionen waren echt sie
könnten ihre definition von kunst ändern
und sagen in der kunst geht es um etwas
anderes als darum emotionen zu wecken
dann funktioniert es vielleicht nicht
aber so lange wir überzeugt sind dass
kunst menschliche gefühle anrühren soll
werden computer schon bald bessere
künstler sein als die meisten menschen
gremium natürlich habe ich mir die ganze
zeit die frage gestellt und damit komme
ich eigentlich zurück zum anfang unseres
gesprächs zur bewertung nämlich ich habe
mich die ganze zeit gefragt finden sie
eigentlich die geschichte die sie
erzählen selber attraktiv ich meine
möchten sie gerne in dieser welt leben
wie ich schon sagte meine aufgabe als
historiker ist nicht zu sagen das ist
gut das ist schlecht seien sie
optimistisch oder pessimistisch
ich versuche einfach zu verstehen was in
die welt um uns herum geschieht und wir
sind den nächsten jahrzehnten und
generationen womöglich weitergeht
das ist meine erste und wichtigste
aufgabe
und natürlich muss ich darauf hinweisen
dass die technologie nicht eine
bestimmte zukunft vorgibt
wir können sie nutzen um völlig
verschiedene gesellschaften zu errichten
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert standen ins
neue technologien zur verfügung wie
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge radio fernsehen
und elektrizität
diese technologien konnten wir nutzen um
kommunistische diktaturen faschistische
regime oder liberale demokratien
aufzubauen das fernsehen gab es zb
überall
und es ging von den menschen ab was sie
damit machen das gleiche geschieht im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert wir haben
neue technologien wie künstliche
intelligenz und biotechnologie und so
weiter aber diese geben nicht nur eine
form von zukunft vor
sie eröffnen verschiedene möglichkeiten
und es liegt an uns weise zu entscheiden
wie wir sie einsetzen
absolut zukunft lässt sich gestalten
zukunft ist nicht einfach etwas was wir
beschreiben sondern wir müssen uns damit
auseinandersetzen um das gestalten und
denn genau deswegen frage ich sie noch
einmal zieh dich so viel wissen über die
zukunft wie finden sie denn dass wir die
zukunft gestalten
ich würde sagen die wichtigste frage ist
das leiden
wir sollten so gut wie möglich zu
verstehen versuchen was leiden bedeutet
dass dessen tiefere ursache ist und wie
wir es auf der ganzen welt verringern
können und jede technologie kann je
nachdem wie sie eingesetzt wird leiden
entweder vergrößern oder verringern
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel nicht von
menschen sondern von tieren
wenn man sieht wie wir andere tiere
behandeln
vor allem nutzt ihre kühe schweine und
hühner sind das die bemitleidenswertes
in lebewesen der welt
es ist unglaublich welch immenses leid
die fleisch und milch industrie
milliarden tieren zufügt die
biotechnologie kann dieses leid entweder
vergrößern oder verringern
man kann sie dazu benutzen um kühe
schweine und hühner zu züchten die mehr
fleisch produzieren und dabei völlig
außer acht lassen was das für die tiere
bedeutet sie können aber die
biotechnologie auch nutzen um so genannt
sauberes fleisch oder zellen fleisch zu
produzieren nämlich fleisch das aus
celle
gezüchtet wird genau um steaks essen zu
können muss man keine kuh großziehen und
dann töten
man kann das steak ganz einfach aus
zellen herstellen das wurde bereits
gemacht vor vier jahren kostete ein
künstliches steak 300.000 dollar
heute sind es nur noch elf dollar mit
der richtigen investitions und
forschungsstrategie werden wir in zehn
jahren künstliche stakes und hamburger
billiger verkaufen als schlachtfleisch
diese entscheidung können wir treffen
wir haben sondern ich glaube das spricht
jetzt auch nicht nur der historiker aus
ihnen sondern sie leben ja selber auch
als veganer sie danken in diesem buch
auch ihren drei hunden für die hunde
perspektive die sie diesem buch ein
stückweit gegeben haben sie lachen weil
natürlich vielleicht ein bisschen
ironisch gemeint aber trotzdem
interessiert es mich was ist eine wunde
perspektive oder auf tragen die hunde
bei dazu wie sie auf die welt blicken
sie erinnern uns daran dass menschen
nicht die einzigen lebewesen mit
gefühlen emotionen und sinneseindrücken
sind die einzigen lebewesen die leiden
oder glücklich sein können wenn wir an
die zukunft denken müssen wir uns
bewusst sein inwiefern wir mit unserem
handeln zum leid oder glück andere tiere
beitragen
wir dürfen nicht nur die menschen
berücksichtigen sind auch ein mensch der
sehr viel meditiert und wenn ich sie so
höre über das mitgefühl sprechen frage
ich mich ob das vielleicht auch einen
zusammenhang sie meditieren täglich zwei
stunden die bafana mit intention sie
gehen auch 30 bis 60 tage pro jahr in
die berge für sich ganz in die ruhe ohne
irgendwelche computer das ist ja
eigentlich berühmt an dieser art von
meditation dass es da auch darum geht
nicht nur zur ruhe zu kommen und sich zu
beobachten den atem zu beobachten
sondern auch mit gefühl
ist es etwas was sie spezifisch aus
dieser meditation ziehen
das habe ich von dir wie pass anna
meditation gelernt die ich tatsächlich
praktizieren
für mich lautet die wohl wichtigste
frage was ist realität was ist real
unser geist produziert ständig
geschichten märchen und fantasien die
verhindern dass wir die realität sehen
meditation ist für mich keine flucht vor
der realität sondern eine methode um mit
ihr in kontakt zu kommen um die
fantasien und fiktiven geschichten die
unser geist ständig produziert zu
durchschauen
es beginnt mit sehr einfachen dingen
als ich vor 17 jahren anfing zu
meditieren doktorierte ich in oxford und
wollte die wie pass einer meditation
kennen lernen
die erste übung war sehr einfach wir
müssen nur den atem beobachten der durch
die nase ein und ausströmte
das war alles wir mussten ihn nicht
kontrollieren sondern nur beobachten wie
er ein und ausströmte ich war an meiner
doktorarbeit und dachte ich bin doch
intelligent ich kenne meinen geist und
kann meine aufmerksamkeit kontrollieren
aber es gelang mir nicht länger als zehn
sekunden
ich versuchte mich auf meinen atem zu
konzentrieren und schon war mein geist
weg und beschäftigte sich mit
erinnerungen geschichten und fantasien
da realisierte ich dass ich nicht über
meinen geist wusste und meine
aufmerksamkeit nicht unter kontrolle
hatte doch wie kann man sich erhoffen
viel tiefere wahrheiten wie den ursprung
des leidens in sich drin zu beobachten
oder die welt zu verstehen wenn man
etwas so einfaches wie den atem der
durch die nase ein und ausströmt nicht
beobachten kann
so begann ich meine meditationspraxis
und in den 17 jahren lernte ich mich zu
konzentrieren und meinen geist zu klären
um mich und die welt ein wenig besser zu
verstehen
vor allem die tiefe ursache des leidens
in meinem leben und in der welt anfängt
um dich ihre thesen von freuen dass sie
gesagt haben
wichtig wäre ihnen dass wir den wert des
mitgefühls kultivieren können wir den
hoffen dass diese neuen menschen
mitgefühl haben werden können wir hoffen
dass auch in der roboter cyborgs
androide mitgefühl haben werden
nicht unbedingt es hängt davon ab wie
wir uns selber verändern
und alle diese neuen technologien und
produkte konzipieren eine gefahr ist
dass sie auf die bedürfnisse der
wirtschaft des militärs und der politik
ausgerichtet sein werden die zukünftigen
menschen werden dann viel effizienter
seien aber nicht unbedingt mitfühlender
moralische oder glücklicher als wir eine
ganz kurze frage zum schluss juval
harari karl valentin hat mal gesagt
früher war die zukunft auch besser
stimmen sie ihm zu nein nein ich denke
jede generation erwartet extrem viel von
der zukunft hat aber auch große angst
davor
diesbezüglich unterscheiden wir uns
nicht von früheren generationen
doch heute ist es schwieriger denn je in
der menschheitsgeschichte sich
vorzustellen wie die welt in 20 oder 30
jahren sein wird
früher hatten die menschen wenigstens
eine grobe vorstellung davon wie die
welt 30 jahre später aussehen könnte
lebte man im mittelalter wusste man
nicht ob man im jahr darauf von den
mongolen eingenommen oder von einer
epidemie heimgesucht wurde
aber man konnte sich ziemlich genau
vorstellen wie die menschen in 30 jahren
aussehen und für ihren lebensunterhalt
sorgen würden
heute haben wir keine ahnung wie der
arbeitsmarkt und sogar die menschliche
körper in 30 oder 50 jahren aussehen
wird
das hat viele praktische folgen
es ist nicht nur eine philosophische
diskussion wir haben zum beispiel keine
idee was wir den kindern heute
diesbezüglich in der schule beibringen
sollen
denn wir wissen schlichtweg nicht in was
für einer welt sie in 30 jahren leben
werden sich lohnt die geschichte zu
studieren und visionen zu entwickeln die
es weitergehen soll
ich danke ihnen sehr für dieses gespräch
dankeschön
am ostersonntag spielt mein kollege yves
bost den faden der zukunft weiter er
trifft den schweizer schriftsteller jona
fischer und fragte ihn der fortschritt
auch voran bringt oder ob die optimisten
im silicon valley naiver träumer sind
und jetzt gleich sehen sie ein porträt
über einen der so markige sätze schrieb
wie die ersten menschen waren nicht die
letzten offen
erich kästner war aber nicht nur für
viele pornos gut zusammen ein
brillianter beobachter seiner zeit
bleiben sie dran
genießen sie den sonntag bis bald
[Musik]